[Music]  it was the night before Christmas on a  set lit so bright a director was  planning an awesome Delight to make a  Marvel special with some holiday fun  that man was none other than director  James Gunn  it is the very first thing ever  conceived from Marvel Studios for Disney  plus it's a fantastic story vomited from  the brain of a Mad genius action on the  set of volume two James Gunn said we  should do a holiday special  Merry Christmas  we all had a laugh we thought that would  be great and then they growed it like  three days  [Music]  the holiday special it's like awesome  this has been a real joyful shoot  because I get to work with a lot of  people I really love  I think audiences are really going to be  excited it's probably going to be played  every year for the rest of our lives  coming with us as a Christmas present  [Music]